Greg Anthony back here on the program
how are you Greg I'm doing great rich
how are you I'm doing well it's draft
night what's your draft memory what was
your draft like night like Greg oh man
it's an incredible experience you know
in a lot of ways you know you have the
two dreams right you dream of playing in
the NBA and you dream of being drafted
to the NBA and so it's a it's a bit
surreal because you really don't know
even though you have some assurances as
you get right down to the nitty-gritty
so but when you actually hear your name
called man it is like one of the most
incredible experiences it's a the
ultimate in validation as an athlete to
have that transpire so for me it was
incredible as I know it will be for each
and one of these kids tonight
where were you specifically we were in
the draft are we at New York City you
know we were in the green room basically
they brought all the guys there were
loud picks they're much like what you're
going to see tonight and so you know I
had my uncle there and my my agents and
some family friends and you know it's
just you know it's just an awesome honor
you know it's a culmination of all that
hard work all that speculation you know
all that doubt and and then the finally
have it all come together man on that
draft I it's the coolest feeling still
probably my fondest memory to this date
it is to have your name called on draft
night know what suit did were you
wearing I was cleaner than the Board of
Health man I was saying you know I I had
on some lavender pants with a I think of
over like a brown tweed jacket with some
some Labrador lavender imprints into it
I was clean you're not
IIIi came with it that night you know as
we did you know I was cleaning it in and
I am looking back on it I will say that
not that Dan there you were 12th overall
12th overall to the Knicks and Larry
Johnson your teammate going first
overall that night man I mean what a one
in a Tyrell Brandon went right before
you the Cleveland Cavaliers
who were right front and center right
now Greg Anthony for tonight's draft
rumors are just flying everywhere that
they're trying to make some big moves in
this draft to just get LeBrons attention
before he decides on his option on June
29th what do you think the Cavs need to
do over the next few days to maybe even
pull something off like that for LeBron
I don't think the drafts gonna play a
role as much talent as you have coming
in on this dress none of these guys are
ready to make the kind of impact that
can get you over the hump to win a
championship so if you're Cleveland
that's not going to play a role in my
estimation as to whether or not he comes
back it's the potential deals that you
might be able to pull off the guys that
you could bring in that are ready to
play and play at a high level that's the
only way and only scenario I see where
LeBron James could return to Cleveland
I just don't again I love this trailer
it Aton could fall to the - the Cavs and
I don't think it changes anything and
again not because the talent isn't ready
but or is it incredible it's just that
they're not ready to impact at that
level it's one thing to play in the NBA
right as a young player it's another to
go and help a team win and win big and
so that's going to take a couple years
especially because these kids are
basically only one year removed from
high school so what about the other side
of this Greg let's say you're the Cavs
and you call up RC Buford of the Spurs
and you say how does Kevin Love and our
eighth overall selection sound for Kawhi
Leonard how do you respond to that if
I'm RC Buford yes I don't I don't know
that that gets it done at all and listen
I think Kevin Love is acquitted himself
quite nicely I think he's a proven
commodity but it just would be hard and
I do think they're going to be much
better offers for Kawhi Leonard than
that you look at the assets that Boston
has you look at the assets that the
Lakers have and the other thing is if
you're gonna trade a guy like Kawhi
Leonard
I don't necessarily want a aging star I
don't want a guy on the back nine of his
career I want somebody who has a chance
to emerge and be an incredible talent
for the next five to ten years and so
that's why I think teams like LA and in
Boston are in a much better situation in
order to make a deal with San Antonio
and if the rumors are true and Kauai has
already let it be known that he intends
to re-sign in LA or wants to sign in LA
I don't know that you would even risk
that because if he doesn't give you the
guarantee that he's going to resign then
you're basically giving away a ton of
talent and it's no different than what
OKC's dealing with right now if Paul
George doesn't resign they're all they
did to get him is for not so you know
you can't in this day and age take the
risk of making a blockbuster deal for a
guy that has no intention of pre signing
with you Gregg Anthony's part of NBA
TV's stress coverage tonight Turner
Sports Greg Anthony back here on the
show let's dig a little bit deeper into
this because I brought this up a little
bit on yesterday's show and I haven't
really heard this discussed and
involving Kawhi Leonard because he's
such a spectacular two-way player and
he's young and he has so much talent and
can bring LeBron to wherever he is if
that is intent if that is the intention
of the team that acquires Kawhi Leonard
Gregg is the idea that if the rumors are
true that he really wasn't all that hurt
but had feelings hurt and thus was
sitting out this season to create this
moment that he could use for maximum
leverage would you as a teammate be
concerned to bring somebody like that
into your locker room first let me
answer this way first and foremost that
isn't true okay I know with certainty
that's not true having said that if it
were true
absolutely you'd have a concern more
importantly I think as an organization I
would have a concern because you can you
would never want to get a hold an
organization hostage like that right
like that that one
would never be acceptable within the
locker room within the front office
what's in the league for that matter so
so I bet that would not be the case and
it wasn't the reality is this his injury
was misdiagnosed by San Antonio
and and that's what basically created
the situation where there's a lack of
trust and rightfully so I would have an
issue as a player with that because your
career is finite right like and he's
also coming into the midst of where you
know he's about to sign a mega contract
he's a proven commodity he's right smack
dab in the beginning of the midst of his
crime and so it would create some
uncertainty in your mind and so now the
way it all played out after that is what
I think even more than a misdiagnosis I
think the way that San Antonio dealt
with it publicly didn't help their cause
and so that's why we're in a situation
now where it's very likely that he won't
Reese I which you know was unfortunate
for San Antonio because he's become the
kind of player he is there but you know
these things do happen and sometimes
guys want to go elsewhere they try to
maximize their opportunities to win or
whatever it is whatever the priorities
may be but it is unfortunate but again
this all creates an incredible interest
for this upcoming offseason because of
LeBron Kawhi Paul George all these a
list-maker superstars they're going to
potentially have an impact in terms of
changing the power structure in the NBA
yeah so and also Chris Paul though I
just want to get to in a second so just
to recap here you don't think there's an
opportunity well there's an opportunity
you don't think the chances are likely
that the way that Popovich and the Spurs
were able to put the toothpaste back in
the tube with LaMarcus Aldridge last
year when he was requesting exit visas
from San Antonio you don't think that's
going to happen with Kawhi Leonard no no
because this one had the thing with
LaMarcus is his issue was actually more
on the court from the stand point and
pop even acknowledged this that he made
a mistake
in terms of how he utilized him he was a
guy that had been you know a nine year
pro had established himself as one of
the best players in league and you
decided he wanted to have him do things
differently and he said that was a
mistake on my part and they had a
heart-to-heart about that this one is a
little bit different again it starts
with the misdiagnosis and then just the
way they went about it because there was
never any public embarrassment of
LaMarcus Aldridge from poeple that
organization and and I just got a sense
that because Kauai we never heard from
them I just got a sense that where the
way those things were they basically
done so much damage that it will be
irreparable I there now if you like
telling your wife you want a divorce and
then trying to walk that one back broken
the trust I don't know that you could
you could repair that one and I think
that's this is somewhat similar we're
gonna hear more about it obviously as
they've had a meeting now but I do still
think it'd be unlikely you'll see Kauai
in San Antonio so Greg Anthony in the
couple minutes we have left here let's
let's hit on Chris Paul and the you know
obviously he has an opportunity to stay
in Houston or maybe join LeBron wherever
the question is is do you see a scenario
over the next 2-3 weeks playing out
where a team is able to compile enough
stars to actually take Golden State down
do you think that yes yes in fact you
know it was somewhat cryptic but in
essence that's what LeBron was saying in
all those press conferences during the
finals he was talking about how high the
IQ has to be how many stars you have to
have he's basically laying out the
blueprint for whomever that team is
that's going to make a push for him what
else they have to be able to do in order
to land it and so who are the guys that
fit that profile Chris Paul is one of
them right
know that for a fact Paul George I think
Kawhi Leonard now comes into play so I
think all these guys are the types of
players that LeBron was thinking about
when he's talking about being in a
situation where they can beat a team
like Golden State it's going to take
that and and I think that's really what
he was saying to the basketball
community and and and I guarantee you
that those those owners in front
office's for taking notes and and trying
to devise a strategy that's going to put
them in a situation where they're going
to be able to compete to not only land
LeBron but compete with the great Golden
State Warriors great chatting with you
Greg let's chat down one please you got
it my friend right back at you that's
Greg Anthony at Greg Anthony 50 and you
could catch NBA TV's coverage of the
draft tonight starting at 7:00 Eastern
Time Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience